Brody do you remember this deep and  delicious I do you know I tried one  recently it was great when I was a kid  but keep your expectations low oh well I  got it for five bucks  a little bit to make it look a little  more Gourmet and also turn it into a  hunger crushing cup  let's start with a little drizzle of PB  I'm gonna add some banana some boobs and  some fresh strawberries and I'm going to  top it off with some peanuts and I feel  like peanuts lost the health Halo  Lottery when it comes to the nut world  but peanuts actually have the highest  amount of protein of all the nuts I mean  not according to Courtney's fertility  doctor  all right so we got protein fiber and  healthy fats in our peanuts and our  peanut butter plus lots of extra fiber  in our berries I feel like this is a  huge upgrade Brody what do you think uh  there's literally nothing that you  think that would make me eat it oh come  on snob